we make way for Mike Francesa the WFAN
talk-show host and a man who helped
create this crazy industry of sports
talk radio and he joins us now Mike good
morning thanks for joining us let me ask
you your first reaction when you heard
that was being benched and really any
credibility shocking not the way the
giant wave try and finish as strong as
possible to care who's in their building
the last week of the season if you're
Wellington that way it's John I always
dream Leon giant like do you think that
this coach made this decision on his own
Mike I do I think he initiated it
I don't know that for sure but I think
and I really believe that there's two
things going on here one bowl of tea and
Jerry so desperate number two I don't
think this coach has ever felt that
Elias completely implemented his system
which would make sense if he longed for
the system that finding he always has
them the other thing is I think if they
felt they could move it off this year
and remember they said they're trying to
win the game so they also started to go
with the both quarterbacks and start to
look at players well wait a second you
can't do both you can't tell me that you
tell the quarterback he's not playing
for quarters when you don't know how he
plays the first two quarters how can you
tell me then you're trying to win the
game
so their messages muddled that's been
the case all year they have fun
completely out of control I think
they're trying to get it to next year
and send all the dialogue in the next
year hoping that they'll get to next
year I think they're desperate and they
say the owner bought in that's the
hardest part to believe he bought into
this who do you think's more likely to
stay next season Ben McAdoo or Eli
Manning but I don't think he will be
here either
I think Eli's career with the Giants I
mean he might he might be back in the
game this week because it doesn't even
sound like they're gonna address the
third quarterback this week Eli's gonna
be number two so he might want to play
in like you know two minutes of the game
who knows you know you know my kid not
cold
but Eli might play again I think Eli's
career is over
I think the Giants will finish low
enough they'll definitely draft the
quarterback and then I think they'd be
motivated to play that quarterback just
like they were motivated to jettison
Kurt Warner and play Eli which I thought
was the right move at the time when they
did it and so with Kurt Warner on board
with it and he went off to Arizona and
had a great couple of years and Eli went
on to his career so I think he'll I
would understand that there'd be a
market for Eli I think there'd be a
couple of teams interested in him
because he's very good in the big game
he's very good with good teams
I think he's got football left so I
don't think Eli will be here after this
year but I would say his extremely
remote that I could do or Reese will be
here next year do you think the reaction
would be different or what do you think
the reaction would be if Davis Webb was
the guy who was getting the chance
instead of Geno Smith Oh Wallace far
less angry much more measured if he had
sold it the right way and to me that was
what it was all about presentation if he
had said listen we love you like we
honor what he did here but we need to
look at our quarterbacks and especially
Webb because where it might be in a
position to draft one we need to look at
our inventory that's the most important
thing right now
everybody would understood that that's
not how they delivered this what they
said with this was the right move for
this team for this week's game
that is impossible for anybody to
believe nor digest and that's what
caused the fire school he's Mike
Francesa WFAN talk-show host people
owners make these mistakes every year
Mike there's certain guys who were
coordinators and they're meant to be
coordinators we always feel like that
you do well as a coordinator that means
you should be elevated to a head coach I
just never got the feeling that Ben
McAdoo had head coaching qualities did
you you know I saw some things last year
Dan and you never know listen I always
make the point the most storied
coordinator of any generation was
villains Walker he was the architect of
the great Miami defense we heard as much
about him as we almost did Don Shula he
came to the Giants he went seven and 24
is the head coach they ran a night of
town he was miserable you never know if
a coordinator great coordinators are
terrible head coaches long Turner
Wade Phillips great coordinators
terrible head coach there is no
connection between the two I saw some
glimmers last year but it's funny he
slipped his hair back this year and
missing dumber than a brick since day
one I mean I don't know if it's that
there's a correlation yes what some
things that were okay this year it has
been the wrong moment the wrong
statement the wrong turn since day one
and this team has been spiraling out of
control since Beckham got hurt in the
preseason they didn't handle that well
they didn't know how to handle it they
built this team around beckham's
explosiveness they were on more of
Beckham's ins explosives they never
disciplined them which hurt this team
dramatically and it was all built about
getting the ball the better when he got
hurt this French and training camp when
he got hurt the preseason game it
destroyed the season in the 30 plus
years you've been doing this the worst
run organization you've come across is
who in New York you know that's a tough
one is a couple who have been really bad
at times really dysfunctional but you
know I would say that you would have to
think that the Jets have been probably
pound for pound the worst the Knicks
have made a lot
bad decisions but remember they did have
the Riley run which was superb I would
say day in and day out it's been the
Jess except for the Parcells G as
they've been first but we've had a lot
of teams that have been run at times
very poorly whether it's the Jets the
Knicks the Mets you can go down the line
very few the Giants and the Yankees
almost always are really on a different
level and held completely differently
with enormous esteem this is very
unguent like this is almost thought to
be giant pre 80 remember the giant had
an incredibly dysfunctional period from
64 until 80
they're almost spinning back into that
mode right now these Mike Francesa
finals show by the way December 15th at
least the final show on WFAN could you
imagine not being on the air yesterday
to have this played out you know like
hand delivered for you that's gonna be
the hardest part days like like
yesterday without the forum without the
audience and you know this and you
understand this would be almost
intolerable for me really almost
impossible so that'll be the hardest
part when you have days like yesterday
you run to the microphone I mean you
live for days like that and they're
gifts I mean they're just they're
special
you know the whole city's old
everybody's wired in so those are days
when when they happen and they will when
I'm not on the air they will be very
tough today but will you have the
platform to still be able to do this on
a daily basis when you leave wsan I
believe yes you know I can't talk about
that now but I believe I will it'll
probably be more towards April or May
before we get to talk about it but it's
in the it's in the building stage right
now but I believe I really up my good to
talk to you good luck here and then as
happy holidays that's a mic Francesa
for more Dan Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]